all right I think we're set up okay um
Matt scoot up up
scoot down that's good Ryan looking a
little more attentive please thank you a
lot of use here okay you ready yeah
all right ready okay cool thank you so
much for doing this by the way thank you
please you don't know how much this
means to me
yeah that hats a little lower on the
grips either better a minute okay all
right man okay so feel good yeah ready
because hello everybody my name is Mark
Clark
welcome to let's play surgeon simulator
in real life we're gonna be working on
we're gonna be okay Mac you were
actually about to go down and see that
so that's what I was worried about
that's what I was see I asked you before
you in a few earth speaking literally
just kind of kind of glossed over it
right you're playing surgeon assuming
they're what happens in the game we
think cut into the patient you take out
his organs yeah this isn't play pretend
this is actually that's no it's all
surgeon simulator it's told surgeon
simulator realize the video have you not
seen the minecraft in real life we
didn't just do minecraft we did
minecraft in real
where we probably do the real life I
thought those were effects like in After
Effects oh my god alright so not easy so
we're gonna get into this we're gonna
cut them open there's gonna be a lot of
blood so that's why you got the mask
anyway so I'm not ready yeah drop this
drill bits I'm trying to break it Ryan
just a phone but really this is gonna be
a lot of use if you can just everything
has to be about the fuse like what about
the safety it's like oh my have you seen
safety on YouTube it doesn't exist I'm
fine with this right this is this is one
he asked for the new clip if you take my
heart oh I never have to worry about the
risk of having a heart attack
absolutely it's like saying if I take
your lungs out you don't you no longer
have the risk of drowning no absolutely
I just slice into your neck all right
for really stands out so you're gonna
put this blade against his throat
hopefully gills will just appear no cuts
no cuts no that's right okay no cuts can
we agree that no cure no cuts no but us
hand to God no cuts mark that's a gun it
doesn't cut surgeon and guns don't go
together baby boo it's good thank you
all right so we're gonna penetrate into
his chest ready I probably do another
you always worry about it your prints
are on the trail and the guns okay
honestly would feel better if we just
put charge the battery rethink things
Emily its marks video do you think you
got the successful baby things
do you think I have anywhere by thinking
about what I did before I get it you
think I got anywhere on do too okay okay
I'm not gonna be permission to do this
if you post it I am I'm full I'm filing
the lawsuit or something against a lot
of useful is that someone didn't give
you permission to use
Oh